im bild-interview hat jetzt friedrich
merz darüber gesprochen dass er nicht
nur davor warnt dass es jetzt eine
pleitewelle geben könnte sondern wir
eigentlich schon mittendrin stecken
bild trifft friedrich merz zum interview
was sagt er dazu wir in deutschland die
pandemie gehandhabt wurde
im wesentlichen hat die deutsche politik
und haben die deutschen gesundheitsämter
die deutschen krankenhäuser es richtig
gemacht sagen sie mir ein land auf der
welt das durchgreifend besser dasteht
als deutschland also wir haben uns hier
im augenblick glaube ich keine vorwürfe
zu machen
aber trotzdem bleibt es ein
abwägungsprozess und dieser
abwägungsprozess wird auch mit
rückschlägen verbunden sein
ob ballermann oder berlin in den letzten
wochen sieht man immer wieder bilder von
menschen die ausgelassen feiern als gäbe
es kein corona was sagt er zu diesen
bildern ich kann das vollkommen
verstehen dass die menschen gerade bei
diesen guten wetter jetzt gerne nach
draußen wollen und auch wieder feiern
wollen wieder zusammen sein wollen
wieder freunde treffen wollen
aber bitte es ist nicht zu verantworten
die gefahr ist zu groß und deswegen kann
ich mich nur jedem appell anschließen
passen sie auf es ist zu früh
es ist so viel es geht zu schnell
könnte die zweite welle zu einem
erneuten lockdown führen es wird sehr
schwierig werden der bevölkerung einen
zweiten lockdown zu vermitteln
ich sehe vor allem die schulen die
schülerinnen und schüler aber auch die
kinder in den kindertagesstätten und in
den kindergärten
das erfordert viel überzeugungsarbeit
viel augenmaß viel abwägung aber auch
für die deutsche wirtschaft ist die
situation äußerst schwierig ich finde
auch die wirtschaftsführer die
unternehmen die gewerkschaften haben
sich sehr verantwortungsvoll verhalten
in den letzten wochen und monaten aber
das muss auch für die nächsten wochen
und monate so bleiben wir sind noch
nicht durch
stichwort wirtschaftskrise wie sieht es
mit den prognosen für 2021 aus für die
deutsche wirtschaft ist die situation
insgesamt sehr schwierig es wird auch in
den nächsten wochen und monaten
schwierig bleiben
wir haben gerade in dieser woche den
ersten konjunktureinbruch bestätigt
bekommen wir haben jetzt wirklich eine
rezession in deutschland im zweiten
quartal in folge zurück gehende
wirtschaftliche leistung
meine vermutung ist das wird auch das
ganze jahr 2020 durchschlagen und ich
bin sehr skeptisch ob die prognosen für
das jahr 2021 alle eintreten wollen wir
es mal zusammen hoffen sicher ist es
nicht